here's how you turn a negative into a
positive not that it was all that
negative but antoine winfield jr in
response to the week 12 deuces that were
thrown at him by tyree kill through the
deuces at hill once it was obvious that
the tampa bay buccaneers would beat the
chiefs
in super bowl 55 7 815 fine
antoine winfield has matched that fine
with a charity donation which is awesome
and the buccaneers are matching it as
well so more than fifteen thousand
dollars is going to go to a middle
school in tampa now hill has been fined
in the past there's this argument going
around that hill has never been fined
for throwing up the deuces on his way to
the end zone i interviewed him about it
several years ago before he ever was
fined for it in 2019 they got him for it
at least once 10 grand plus was defined
then
and and that there's a difference
between
i'm not defending it there's a
difference though between when you run
to the end zone and you kind of throw
that up on your way right to the end
zone and get in a guy's face and
sticking the fingers in his face because
the whole purpose of the rules against
taunting are to prevent the kind of
behavior that could start a fight on the
field and what winfield did is more
likely to result in pushing and shoving
and punching and kicking and everything
else that goes along with fighting than
what hill does although hill should have
been fined for it every time it's
taunting every time yeah and it's
amazing the number of those that get
missed but when you go right up to a guy
after a play
and it's just you and him right and
you're and you stick your fingers in his
face it's unavoidable that it's going to
get flagged it's unavoidable that it's
going to get fined and it was worth
every penny for antoine winfield because
he was waiting all those weeks for that
opportunity to give it back to tyree
kill after seeing the deuces
in week 12. that's right and he made all
that extra playoff money so he could he
could afford to throw a few you know
dollars out the window but i i see it
like you do i mean yes
you know by the letter of the law it's
taunting but i look at it more as like
it's not to anybody specific it's like
deion sanders high stepping into the end
zone when he used to get a pick six or
return a punt return for a touchdown you
know was he taunting people i mean i
guess by the letter of the law he could
he was you know we see lots of guys do
things as they get close to the end zone
i mean we've seen marshawn lynch you
know jump up and grab his crotch and do
all that type of stuff right i mean is
that taunting no he's just doing
something cool as he runs he's been fine
he's been fine i know well that's a
little crazy and i don't want to tell
you all that yes but but i don't think
it's personal what tyreek hill is doing
so i hope they don't find him for doing
that until he gets up into somebody's
face and does it that's a different
story that's the thing he's so far away
from the defenders typically at that
point that when he throws up two fingers
you really can't tell who he's throwing
him up at and and
now that they've dramatically relaxed
the rules regarding celebrations because
it wasn't that long ago that it was no
fun league and you couldn't do anything
you couldn't use the ball as a prop
couldn't have joint celebrations they
really went the other way so okay you
can you can celebrate
like it's 1999 when you get to the end
zone but you can't do anything before
you get to the end zone on your way to
the end zone that would be kind of like
a pre-celebration i think that just
makes it a greater area yeah but you get
up in a guy's face afterward and look it
it's it's it's meaningless like it's so
much ink is being spilled over the
contrast between hill and winfield
winfield knew he was going to get
flagged he knew he was going to get
fined it was worth it to him and it
didn't affect the game he waited he
didn't do it was over the first half
right it was when when we all knew it
was done it's 31-9 the last gasp for the
chiefs with four minutes or so left
interception in the end zone peace out
see you later tyree kill uh a little a
little karma a little a little what's
good for the goose is good for the
gander whatever it is it gets a it's a
little payback for the last time he did
it and uh i got no problem with it and i
think winfield has no problem with the
fact that he got fined for it that's the
thing people say it's a no fun league
because somebody gets flagged or fined
they still did it they still did it
right like we still got to be
entertained by it yeah why do we care if
somebody's got to write a check out of
their disposable income to the nfl when
that money goes to charity anyway it's
just an involuntary charitable
contribution yeah no doubt about it no
doubt about it listen it's football it's
a game of emotions sometimes that gets
to you
and it you're right he just he had him
he had him in his sights he he was mad
about what happened earlier that year
and he was going to get his wait for his
moment to get him back he did and if you
watch tv or watch the game back or
anything kyrie kills smiling when he's
doing it he's going like okay yep you
got me all right in my face and blah
blah blah but uh you said all the right
things so but what what now what are we
going to talk we could talk about brady
well let me add let me just add this
real quickly
you know it could be in the nfl's
interest to change the name of the fine
to something that better connotes where
the money goes you're right almost like
a swear jar you know that
that that
not that you don't want to encourage the
behavior that that would be punished
financially but the one thing that
rarely gets discussed is this money goes
to good causes this isn't getting
stuffed into roger goodell's pocket he
doesn't get a bonus at the end of the
year for the number of guys who are fine
he doesn't get a cut of it the money all
goes to charity and it's a good idea
mike they need they need they need it
maybe if they come up with a different
word for it people won't get as
triggered when someone gets fined
they'll just say hey it's more money for
the swear jar and that money's going to
go to a good cause all right i like that
mike i really do i can get behind that i
think that's pretty cool actually
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports